spider-man into the spider-verse has
finally arrived in theaters giving
everyone a chance to dig into one of the
most anticipated movies of the year the
movie is also fairly complex blending a
massive cast of characters with
different animation styles multiple
villains and a plotline that hops
dimensions if you're still trying to
figure it all out we are here to help
oh and that weird feeling that's your
spoiler since tingling hey guys actually
from the moment she's revealed as in the
film gwen stacy makes it clear that
she's not interested in making friends
of course that changes over the course
of the film and by the end
she's definitely interested in a
friendship with Miles Morales luckily
these Spider pals have figured out a way
to stay in touch across dimensions when
she seems to visit him right before the
credits roll the film doesn't take the
time at the end to explain why or how
this is actually happening but it's an
obvious setup for a spider gang in the
inevitable sequel Miles Morales learns
throughout the film that he can't just
be spider-man in some kind of magic
automatic way he has to take the leap of
faith and become spider-man in a way
that's true to him we see this in a
thrilling sequence in which he creates
his own spider suit and heads out into
the world with his own unique threats in
the final moments of the film we see
that he's continued his street art
tradition both as Myles and as
spider-man in the end miles carries on
the long tradition of refusing to kill
his nemesis and instead turns kingpin
over to the authorities we know two
things about this universes kingpin for
sure he has considerable resources and
he's absolutely relentless in his
pursuit of getting what he wants chances
are that what he wants most after the
credits his vengeance upon the new
spider-man don't be surprised if he
manages to show up in some fashion in a
sequel into the spider-verse is largely
a mild story but he's not the only
spider-man to learn a lesson in teaching
miles how to use his powers Peter B
Parker also relearn's the lessons of
great power and great responsibilities
that he had to internalize all those
years ago
we're a little tease he is the teacher
who could still do it
you as the student who can judge is not
if good I'm proud of us when we first
meet him he's a spider-man on autopilot
shrugging his way through crime-fighting
while his personal life is in shambles
in meeting miles he finds an opportunity
to teach and to learn about what it is
to be a hero all over again by the time
he returns to his home universe he's a
changed man not just an amazing
spider-man but an amazing man a couple
of months before into the spider-verse
hit theaters Sony released another film
based on a Marvel Comics character with
a very close spider-man connection venom
that film included two post-credit
scenes one of which seemed to be just an
extended clip to promote into the
spider-verse which included an important
title card telling us that the upcoming
animated film was taking place in
another universe does this mean that Tom
Hardy's venom could show up in future
installments of the spider-verse
franchise the answer is a definite maybe
but that would be a truly wild crossover
indeed miles father Jefferson is a
police officer who views spider-man as a
menace that is until he sees the new
spider-man in action at the end of the
film his very vocal change of heart
during the final battle helps miles to
defeat kingpin and miles returns the
favor by finally telling his dad he
loves it well sort of officers I love
you we're right it's a big emotional
payoff in the film giving Miles the
opportunity to covertly tell his father
what he's been holding back it might
also be the new spider-man accidentally
hinting at his identity if that's the
case it might not be long before Miles
has outed his spider-man to his parents
in the end Miles Morales is able to send
all of his friends back home and defeat
kingpin still this is a superhero
universe with a sequel on the way so we
know his version of New York City won't
stay quiet for long so who will miles
fight the next time around the clear
contender could be the Green Goblin who
shows up in this film for its first
major fight scene but is ultimately
relegated to a minor role we're betting
the Green Goblin and his alter-ego
Norman Osborn could have a much larger
role to play in the sequel the film's
post-credits scene reveals yet another
spider hero we see a costumed figure
named Miguel jump into the past and get
into an argument with the spider-man
from
the 1967 animated series the Miguel in
question is Miguel O'Hara
aka spider-man 2099 in the comics and in
the film he has the ability to hop
through dimensions which means he could
show up alongside any of into the spider
vs heroes at a moment's notice
keep an eye out for him in the follow-up
of course we all know who we really want
to come back next time we visit the
spider verse I just washed my hands
that's why they're wet no other reason